hey guys Ryan right here I've been
checking out some popular videos on
YouTube catching up on the YouTube world
then I came across this video it's
pretty popular right now called girl
voice it's a short video and I like
short videos my videos should be shorter
but I also like things to be long to
represent
of the super-excited that's not real no
I was incredible was that real I don't
know if that was real man that sounded
way too good now well that was worth my
time 20 seconds of my life that was
truly fascinating to me um that was
great
but I want to meet that guy I want to
talk to me in that voice and then I want
him to blow me but I want him to shave
first
don't like a guy with facial hair down
there I have to have the face I have to
be the man they have to be you know they
have to be bottom basically is what I'm
saying if I'm gonna do gay stuff right
not much what I could say that was that
was a great [ __ ] video I was really
impressed with that if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects that would be cool we do videos
too on YouTube at this point in the
video if you're new to the channel I
like to give shout outs Simon snow
Thomas Rubino you wanted a shout-out
Rubino you must be Italian
Italians are cool I'm half Italian
meaning I got a huge ding-a-ling angling
and I like to do things like this
I dumb son of a [ __ ] show my Robert De
Niro pressure and everyone always goes
ah yo now you're talking to me oh and I
always go you dumb son of a [ __ ] show
ah yeah yo Mary Thomas I thought I'd
give you a shout-out before when you
guys re-request it makes my life yeah
Thomas the choo-choo train an Tiago
marques he said shout-out please
well you're getting your shout out and
Tiago marques you sound like you could
be a Spanish warrior you an Thiago
Marquez get all the punani in the world
to poonanny no one's use that word
forever poonanny and Tiago you got to
teach me your ways man I mean just
having to name my bed I'd be like that
is one sexy [ __ ] you know like
an Antonio Banderas type of guy so yeah
man could you just give me a few tips on
what you do to get a ladies or gay guys
whichever one David McAra s'en could you
give me a shout-out and your other
Scottish subscribers things all right
son you are going to get a shout out to
David McCallum you are a good lot I like
everything you are doing with the
subscribing and the commenting maybe one
day you'll get your deck soaked by me
this whole video is better than that
sucking dick I need and your funny new
theme it's channel needs new trailer
reactions movie reviews and sucking dick
and that's what you're getting
I am Gerard Butler I talked to the right
side of my face or the left side of my
face either way my mouth is over here or
over here